I'm managing the homelessness.
Homeless people have schizophrenia.
Schizophrenia is a genetic disorder.
Nobody knows what the Jews are or how they work,
but it's pretty clear there's a genetic component.
If you can find the g,
figure out what they do and come up with real good treatments.
If black shores for schizophrenia and possibly preventions for schizophrenia,
that indirectly is going to help alleviate the homeless problem.
Right.
So I don't know what to do about the homeless,
but if you can figure out what to do about schizophrenia,
that's going to have some impact on that.
Yes.
It's basically,
yeah,
we'll use your claim to some degree is that these more complex social problems
should be decomposed into isolatable micro problems and its specific solutions
should be sought for them.
And now that's certainly strikes me as an appropriate approach because everybody
is different.
Not everyone is the same reason.
No,
no.
Well that's for sure.
That's for sure won't be on everyone's port for the same route for the same
reason that any stretch of the imagination.
That's right.
Poverty is,
doesn't have one,
because you know what,
these,
and it's not nearly caused by lack of money either,
because that would be a much easier problem to solve,
unfortunately.
It's not so simple.
So the one thing that we're probably getting toward the end,
the one thing I would like to leave your listeners with is really optimism.
These are not dismal problems in perpetuity because the genetic approach,
I think,
and I,
I'm kinda out,
you know,
I'm kind of out there on this.
This is not a mainstream view,
but I think the more something is generic,
the more likely it is we can change it for the good.
And that's why we just should study the genetics of intelligence.
That's why I hope genes have more to do with it.
That environment.